wir sprechen jetzt mit jemanden der die
beiden brüder seit kindesbeinen kennt
uns zugeschaltet ist portugal der
frühere butler von lady di
vielen dank dass sie sich die zeit
genommen es freut mich sehr
[Musik]
aber jetzt müssen sie getrennt beim
begräbnis gehen was glauben sie ist der
wirklich
das wurde ja von prinz philip
organisiert das sind seine wünsche und
die sind von der queen abgesegnet wohin
und der grund weshalb sie so laufen wie
sie dort laufen werden besteht darin
dass william der ältere
henkel ist und in der direkte thronfolge
steht und private dann in der nächsten
er den nächsten schritt machen würde und
dann erst kommt harry und die medien
lesen viel zu viel hinein in die
tatsache dass sie nicht nebeneinander
laufen sie sind ja tatsächlich auch
damals bei der begräbnis ihrer mutter
nicht nebeneinander gelaufen das ist
also eine ganz einfache erklärung
hierfür ja aber dieses mal ist es vor
seinem tor selbst so angeordnet wurde
und auch von der queen entsprechend
abgesegnete sondern das heißt hier
werden die wünsche von priestern voll
das ist genau die art und weise wie er
wollte dass sie dort aufgestellt sind
und bitte vergessen sie nicht das
prinzip auch harry dazu aufgefordert und
ihn dazu ermutigt hat hinter dem sarg
seiner mutter hergehen denn er wollte es
ursprünglich gar nicht prinz philip
sagte gehst du an meiner seite denn ich
gehe an deiner seite wenden mit mir dort
geht und dieses mal zeigt harry seinem
großvater den respekt dadurch dass er
neben dem sack geht
die matte geschickt sie hatte gesagt
dass niemand ein militärisch
gebrauchtwagen sollte
warum glauben sie war das wichtig für
den familienfrieden oder ist das einfach
auch typisch für die queen dass sie
gegen die wünsche ihres ehemannes sich
entscheidet um diesen frieden so war und
wegen pro weg musste natürlich prinz
philip jetzt eine sehr viel kleineres
budget preis haben mit sehr viel weniger
gästen und ich glaube in gewisser weise
ist es dadurch persönlicher und
familiärer für die queen und ihre
familien tatsächlich nur sehr wenige
leute sind die dort heute gemeinsam
trauern werden ich glaube dass die queen
nicht wollte dass irgendjemand uniformen
trägt weil es tatsächlich den menschen
dort eher einander an gleich denn die
menschen die hinter dem war
heute gehen werden davon sind einige gar
nicht beim militär gewesen harry hat
nicht mehr die erlaubnis die uniform zu
tragen und hessen oben hat das militär
gedient und peter philips frau nicht und
sie hätten ohnehin keine uniform
getragen
android hat sich von seinen öffentlichen
pflichten zurückgezogen wie lehrer also
auch nicht in der lage eine uniform zu
tragen das heißt die queen wollte
einfach dass das hier alles ein wenig
gleichförmiger gestaltet wird und dass
ihre familie als einheit erscheint und
auch gleicher erscheint so dass man
nicht einzelne leicht herauspicken
könnte sie können natürlich ihre
medaillen tragen um eben zu zeigen dass
sie der krone gedient haben wenn man
also den herren auf die brust schottern
wird man sehen dass einige gedient haben
anderen nicht einige werden mehr
medaillen tragen als andere
perry wird wahrscheinlich mehr medaillen
tragen als sein oder weil er eben auch
aktiv in afghanistan gedient hat harry
hat eine sehr gute beziehung zu seiner
großmutter
er ruft sie regelmäßig sein und er war
auch immer begeistert von seiner
großmutter und sie hat auch sehr viel
für ihn übrig schon seit sie beide
kinder waren die beiden brüder und zu
jeder weihnachten beispielsweise hat
harry immer gefragt was kann ich denn
meinen großeltern zu weihnachten schenkt
die haben doch alles schon und ich habe
dann immer etwas witziges aussuche etwas
aus was vielleicht einfach ist und weil
harry hier der witzbold bei uns ist
immer geblieben ist hat er immer
versucht seine großeltern zum lachen
sondern in einem jahr hat er
beispielsweise ein furzkissen gekauft
unter ein sitzkissen zulegen und er hat
gesagt aber du musst auf jeden fall
darauf achten auf den stuhl seines
großvaters zu legen denn deine
großmutter wäre überhaupt nicht amüsiert
ob ich weiß was du für deine großmutter
kaufen kannst noch holt für mich einen
von diesen kleinen plastik fliegen die
du dann in die zucker in den zucker
behälter tun kannst und wenn sie trinkt
kann sie sich dann darüber erschrecken
dass wir eine wundervolle überraschung
harry war also wirklich immer der
witzbold er hat immer versucht seine
großmutter zum lachen zu bringen genauso
wie sein grossvater ja ganz wunderbare
weihnachtsgeschenke für die großeltern
vielen herzlichen dank für diesen
einblick die brüder da wurde ja harry
immer als witziger als extrovertierter
wahrgenommen und von dem wir immer der
ruhige rationalere sie haben die beiden
brüder dort erlebt als sie groß
gebündelt dass bei ihrer wahrnehmung nun
ganz genau so war immer derjenige der
sich mehr dem lerne hingegeben hat der
immer herrscht da war und es gab einfach
immer leute um ihn herum die ihm schon
früher immer zugeflüstert haben
erinnere dich daran wer du bist und das
du eines tages könig sein wirst und
selbst ihr kindermädchen hat damals
beispielsweise gesagt du kriegst drei
würstchen wenn es das essen gab wir
müssen dich aufbauen um könig zu werden
und herren du kriegst 2 ist also immer
hier einen schritt hinter seinem bruder
zurückgeblieben der immer eine
vorzugsbehandlung bekommen hat außer von
dajana sieht die sieht beide gleich
behandelt hat und jetzt in diesen
krisenzeiten denke ich wäre da ja auch
noch in der mitte zwischen beiden mit
einem arm um jeweils einen ihrer beiden
söhne denn sie ist die einzige die sie
wieder zusammen hätte bringen zusammen
hätte bringen können ich glaube nicht
dass dieses begräbnis nun die zeit oder
der ort sein wird um das zu schaffen
aber wie ist es nun
ihrer meinung nach möglich wieder
frieden zu stiften
das land eingeflogen ist sofort in dem
lokal gegangen er konnte sich mit
niemandem treffen er fährt zum begräbnis
von fonds und wird keine zeit haben für
unterhaltung
die familie darf sich privat nicht
treffen gegen der kopie der regel und
ich glaube dass harry wahrscheinlich
schon heute abend oder morgen früh
wieder in einem flieger sitzen wird um
zu seiner familie nach los einheits
zurückzufliegen
die einzige möglichkeit für sie sich
jetzt zu treffen noch einmal in näherer
zukunft ist am ersten juli wo william
und harry nebeneinander stehen werden
und eine statue zum andenken ihrer
mutter erkennt ordensleute und höhe und
dann werden hoffentlich die kogit regeln
aufgehoben worden sein damit die beiden
sich auch hinsetzen können mit harry mit
seiner familie sprechen kann darüber was
in der königlichen familie geschehen ist
die krise wird heute wahrscheinlich auch
denken dass das kein guter zeitpunkt ist
für einfamilien gipfel oder für eine
diskussion irgendwelche anderen themen
und das ist der tag ist an dem in
philipp ihrem ehemann respekt gezeigt
werden soll
und das schließt alle ein auch harrys
heute mehr respekt zollen jemandem der
es ihnen so viel bedeutet hat ein ganz
besonders schwerer tag für die beiden
brüder
sie müssen heute hinter dem sarg ihres
geliebten großvaters hergehen das wird
natürlich erinnerungen daran mitbringen
als sie hinter dem sarg ihrer geliebten
mutter laufen wunden öffnen
nun will während sich mit sicherheit
auch an 1997 erinnern als die zwölf und
15 jahre alt waren und hinter dem sarg
ihrer mutter hergehen mussten schauen
sie sich heute das gesicht der beiden an
sie werden wahrscheinlich niemandem ins
gesicht schauen immer aus dem umfeld und
ganz besonders gern im und herzog das
immer so er konzentriert sich dann ganz
auf den moment und harry wird sicher
auch daran erinnern wie er hinter dem
sarg seiner mutter her gegangen ist und
auch daran wie eng er dann mal seinem
bruder war aber er wird wahrscheinlich
auch daran denken wenn er
all diesen uniformierten männern vorbei
geht die prinz philip respekt zollen und
auch wegen der tatsache dass er selbst
seiner großmutter gedient hat dann wird
er wahrscheinlich auch darüber
nachdenken ob er das wirklich alles
aufgeben möchte oder sollte denn was wir
heute alles sehen ist natürlich das
öffentliche gesicht dieser familie und
die öffentliche trauer und harry war mal
teil dieses ja dieser rieten ihr hat
seine hat seine uniform auch mit stolz
getragen oder bis zum schluss seine
großmutter auch gebeten die uniform
weiterhin tragen zu dürfen und teil der
streitkräfte bleiben zu lassen aber die
queen hat ihm gesagt hey du bist
entweder ein wirklich arbeiten das
mitglied der königlichen familie oder
nicht du kannst nicht mit einem fuß drin
sein mit einem fußball was möchtest du
nun und er hat sich entschieden und sein
großvater hat ihm wohl gesagt hey du
hättest dich jetzt musst du auch darin
liegen
man kann nicht alles haben das ist eben
wahrscheinlich genau das was die queen
auch ihren henkeln sagen würde
letzte frage an sie herbert werden sie
sich heute den abschied dort darauf
achten was herr william tun und ob es
zeichen der freundschaft oder der
bruderschaft zwischen ja natürlich
schaue ich mir das alles an und ich
erinnere mich natürlich auch daran sich
elf jahre lang neben prinz philip und
der queen gestanden habe ihn gedient
habe dem vielen spaß und das lachen was
wir erlebt haben und natürlich werde ich
mit führen mit der queen die im
augenblick wirklich sehr alleine ist und
eine große lehre an ihrer seite
verspüren müssen und wenn das dann heute
alles vorbei ist werde ich an sie denken
wie sie allein in ihre gemächer sich
zurückzieht in diesen zeiten sondern
scoop.it und ich werde an ihre majestät
denken die den kapitän des schiffes
ihres lebens nun verloren hat aber ich
werde eben natürlich auch herrin über
die beobachten und ich hoffe dass sie
beiden irgendwie wieder zusammenkommen
irgendeine geste zeigen können aber
meine gedanken sind hauptsächlich bei
ihrer majestät und werde wahrscheinlich
auch die ein oder andere träne vergießen
und ich hoffe dass sie vielleicht auch
die branche 3
die prinz philip für sie designt hat
achten sie also heute auch auf ihren
schmuck sie wird perlen tragen und
wahrscheinlich diese wundervolle
diamanten branche die prinz philip ihr
als geschenk überreicht hat eine
erinnerung an prinz philip die für immer
mit ihnen bleiben wird weil es so lustig
war oder so traurig ich habe viele
erinnerungen jedes mal dass ich an
seinem ankleidezimmer vorbei gekommen
bin habe ich gehört wie er dort rechts
und keuchte als er dort sport übung
gemacht hat und er hat in seinem bad
jeden abend ein team in adel bad
genommen
diesen geruch werde ich immer mit riemen
verglichen wird kriegen dieses produkt
gar nicht in england und ich glaube das
ist aus deutschland messner oder so was
ähnliches heißt es ich weiß nicht mal
was es bedeutet aber es ist ein ein öl
ein team und öl dass er sich ins
badewasser getan hat aber als ich meine
frau maria getroffen habe da hat er dann
hat hat prinz philip damals gesagt sie
ist eine zofe am hof und bedeutet mir
viel also achten sie bitte darauf
und dann sagte er ich werde ihnen hier
eine uhr und auch hier einen
kerzenhalter geben damit sie immer an
uns denken können ich habe also eine
sehr persönliche verbindung zur prinz
philip gehabt genau wie meine ehefrau
wir sind sehr traurig über seinen tod er
hat ein sehr gutes leben gehabt
natürlich ein langes leben 99 jahre und
er hat sehr sehr viel in seinem leben
erreicht und hat so viel gutes getan und
dafür sollten wir ihnen heute auch im
kopf behalten wir sollten uns daran
erinnern was er gutes geschaffen hat und
dass er vielen menschen ein grund
gegeben hat zu lächeln und es freut mich
auch sehr zu sehen dass seine
europäische familie bei dem begräbnis
auch repräsentiert sei betont hat diese
30 gästen das ist wirklich gut zu sehen
dass auch sein erbe heutige
repräsentiert wird
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier und vergesst bitte nicht
unseren kanal zu abonnieren